hey what's going on folks today I want
to talk about the little teaser trailer
that was released yesterday during the
announcement of the premiere date and
I'm sure most of you are aware by now
that yesterday was a pretty big day for
Game of Thrones fans Game of Thrones
went live on their Facebook page and
announced that season 7 will premiere on
July 16 2017 and although we still have
a few months to wait things are really
starting to ramp up now the Game of
Thrones marketing and promoting team is
going to be in full force from here on
out and it has me very excited they are
also going to be at South by Southwest
this weekend so there's a pretty good
chance we could get another teaser or
even a trailer very very soon and I
don't know about you but I'm getting
very hyped for Season seven now and I
actually tried to upload a video three
times yesterday about this teaser but
YouTube kept blocking it and sending me
these copyright emails every time even
after I made significant changes to it
so I decided to wait until today and
start over and almost didn't make one at
all today because I noticed how many of
these teaser breakdowns have already
been released by other channels but
after watching some of them I noticed
that there are a few things that no one
has mentioned yet so I want to take the
time now to point these things out and
maybe I'm just looking too far in the
things or maybe I'm right I'll let you
guys be the judge so let's get started
first I just want to say what I loved
about this tease are the most was the
visual effects that it had I think this
is really well done it was very dark and
ominous and I think it's safe to say
that season 7 is going to be very dark
and grim which should go without saying
but this teaser has several famous
quotes from some of our favorite
characters and as the quotes were being
said the sigils would then represent and
take form to what was being said in each
quote which I loved and thought was
really clever way to do this the sigil
teaser starts out with showing the three
heads of a dragon which is obviously
decidua Love House Targaryen but keep in
mind they show all three dragons here at
the very beginning then we get a quote
from Daenerys Targaryen she says I know
what my father was and what he did I
know the Mad King earned his name then
we hear the Mad King say burn them all
this is the marys obviously expressing
that she knows what her father was and
she does not want to rule like
father did she does not want the
reputation that her father had she wants
to break the wheel and do things her way
which in her mind is the right way but
that is still yet to be determined then
we get the famous quote from Robert
Baratheon I will kill every Targaryen I
get my hands on and it's no secret that
Robert Baratheon hated the Targaryen
with the passion hence Robert's
rebellion we also get a quote from
Cersei Lannister everyone who isn't us
is an enemy and I think Cersei has made
it very clear what she is willing to do
to those who oppose her then we get a
line from her son Joffrey which I still
hate to hear to this day sir Ilyn bring
me his head this was at a pivotal moment
in a series when Joffrey won against his
word and had Ned Stark executed instead
of sent to the wall to live out his days
like he had promised to him if he had
only admitted that he lied and tried to
take the throne for himself instead of
swearing fealty to Joffrey the true king
there was a quote from Balin Greyjoy as
well
we are Ironborn we take what we want
beylin delivered this line to his son
feel--and Greyjoy
when vielen tried to strike a deal
between his father and Robb Stark not
only is this obviously a significant
line from Balaam but I think this was
also added in here because of the
growing presence of the Greyjoy's Theon
and Yara are now aligned with Daenerys
and Euron is going to have an even
bigger role during season 7 and he
should also pose a significant threat to
the realm the show hasn't done a very
good job of making you're on a very
intimidating man but in the books you're
on as a savage so I'm hoping during
season seven they are able to get that
across a little bit better then we get
another dreadful line from Roose Bolton
the Lannisters send their regards which
is what he said - Robb Stark during the
red wedding as he plunged his knife into
his abdomen [ __ ] you Bruce sorry about
that but I had to say that we then hear
Lady Olenna say you didn't think I would
let you marry that beast did you and as
she says that you can see the vine wrap
around the lion's paw which I thought
was really cool and really well done and
as they show the Tyrell sigil you can
hear Qyburn say I now pronounce 30 of
the House Lannister
protector of the Seven Kingdoms as he
says that wildfire then engulfed the
Tyrell sigil which is just fantastic
looking I loved what Qyburn said here
too
Cersei is going to be protector of the
Seven Kingdoms really Cersei is going to
protect us as the teaser winds down and
nears the end we then see all the sigils
kind of tangled or clash together as
Daenerys has another quote in which he
says Lannister Targaryen Baratheon stark
Tyrell they're all just spokes on a
wheel
this one's on top and that one is on top
and on and on it spins crushing those on
the ground I really like that quote but
I really like what they did visually as
she said it we then see all the sigil
start to crack and crumble which I
thought was very significant which I
will get back to in a second we get one
more quote though and arguably the most
important quote from in my opinion the
most important character Jon Snow he
says same thing is coming for all of us
there was only one more that matters the
Great War and it is here then we see the
pattern that the knight king always
leaves behind the same pattern we saw
with the children of the forest then it
fades into a giant blue eye named
Macomber no I'm just kidding it then
fades into what is more than likely the
knight Kings eye so let's get into all
of this now what do I think this means
there is one thing I think we should all
keep in mind here this is a season 7
teaser so everything in this teaser is
going to represent what is going to take
place next season not season 8 what some
people have gotten confused
I think the T's are starting off with
the three dragons and Danny's quote
represents her strengths and arrival at
the beginning of next season she is
going to arrive in Westeros with the
biggest force and her three big-ass
dragons
even though Cersei is empowered now
Danny will eventually take that spot but
then we get quote upper quota some
pivotal moments in the series which
perfectly summed up some of the chaos
that has taken place with all the main
players in the game that has led us to
this point in the series and as it nears
the end all the sigils and houses are
clashing and intertwined once again
which Lee
into the sigils cracking and breaking
right before Jon Snow reminds us of the
war that is no longer coming but is now
here at season seven progresses the
realm is going to be in chaos once again
with people still jockeying for position
trying to be the next one to sit on that
iron throne the first thing that popped
in my head when I saw and heard the
sigils cracking and crumbling was the
wall falling it sounds it exactly like a
wall of ice crumbling down and it even
looked like ice breaking it's no secret
that most people assumed the wall would
fall during season seven but I think
this is actually telling us that while
all the houses are tangled together
still fighting for who is in control the
night team will have made it to the wall
and he will be bringing it down which is
exactly why I think we got Jon's quote
right after they showed us these sigils
cracking and falling down he says there
is only one war the Great War and it is
here I think we will get this quote when
John knows that the wall is either being
breached or about to be breached John is
trying to warn everyone and rally
everyone together but everyone is still
going to be fighting with each other
which is why we see that Sybil is all
tangled together while the true threat
is crossing the wall which is exactly
why I think they showed them cracking in
John saying now the war is here now they
have crossed the wall and there is
nothing we can do about it except fight
together if we want to survive I was
talking to cows chicken yesterday about
this teaser and he thought it meant the
same thing and I think most people think
the wall will fall at the end of season
seven but I haven't heard anyone else
say that they think this represents that
in any way listen to those sigils crack
and break apart again I think it sounds
like a giant ice wall breaking almost
like the beginning of an avalanche and
although Daenerys has the biggest force
in three dragons I still think John is
the key figure in all of this he got the
last quote for a reason he's going to be
the one quarterbacking this war against
the others I know most people think
Daenerys is the main player here but
John is the Song of Ice and Fire because
of his parents his blood is V blood he
has the perfect combination say what you
want about his intelligence and
strategies but he is the one that is
going to be needed to win this thing the
dragons are going to play a
big part but John is going to fight the
19:1 verse 1 there is no doubt about
that in my opinion they didn't show us
that epic stare down between them two at
hardhome without us ever getting a
payoff from all that tension being built
up there these two will square up and
that played between them is going to
decide the fate of every living and
non-living person in this world and
there's something else in this teaser I
wanted to point out when the teaser
starts we see three dragons but when it
ends in the sigils are falling apart
they only show two dragons I think we
are definitely going to see a dragon die
by the end of season 7 will it be
resurrected or not as for another
conversation but demo is showing two of
them at the end of this teaser seems
pretty significant to me I think the
season is going to start with three
dragons like they show here and it's
going to end with only two dragons like
they show at the end of this teaser and
they also showed a bear in this teaser
to which is the symbol of house Mormont
so there must be some significance to
that also
there wasn't any Mormont quote but they
did show their bear I think in season
seven the more months will continue to
help John make the north grade again
with a juror coming back and going north
with John he's going to help win this
war which I did make a video about
already where I said Jorah Mormont is
going to survive the game of Thrones
this could just represent Liana's
emergence in the show to which he has
been phenomenal and stolen every single
scene she's ever been in but I think
we're going to see the old bear Jorah
kicking some ass again next season and
once Jorah goes north and has a look at
the threat for himself he will be one of
the men to help John rally the rest of
the forces together to take down the
night king but I think I've rambled on
enough already that's what I took away
from this teaser I think we're going to
lose a dragon next season and I think
while the rest of the realm is still
battling for position the night King
will make his presence felt at the wall
and bring it down the war for the dawn
part two we'll have then begun which Jon
Snow's States at the end of this teaser
comment below though and give me your
thoughts on all this this teaser was
very cool it has me very excited and I
can't wait to see more as we lead up to
the premiere date anyways I hope you all
have a good day
we're taking the time to watch this I
will see you down in the comment section
bye